>> ♪ ♪
>> AS FAR AS NORTH KOREA IS
CONCERNED
CONCERNE
CONCERNED --KNOW.
>> NORTH KOREA BEST NOT MAKE
ANYMORE THREATS TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY WILL BE MET WITH FIRE AND
FURY.
>> NORTH KOREA KIM JONG-UN IS
COMMITTED TO DENUCLEARIZATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP O
PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WILL
MEET KIM JONG-UN BY MAY.
>> WE WON'T HAVE THIS MEETING
TAKE PLACE UNTIL WE SEE CONCRETE
ACTIONS THAT MATCH THE WORDS OF
NORTH KOREA.
NORTH KOREA MADE SOME PROMISES.
>> Bret: AND SARAH SANDERS SAID
8 TIMES THERE NEEDED TO BE
CONCRETE ACTIONS BY NORTH KOREA
BEFORE IT WAS SCHEDULE, THIS
MEETING BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND KIM JONG-UN.
BECAUSE OF THE DIPLOMACY ACTIONS
IN THE PAST.
IN 1994 NORTH KOREA SIGNED
FRAMEWORK AND MOVED FORWARD WITH
THEIR PROGRAM ANYWAY.
2002 TO 2007:
IF ANYONE THOUGHT THAT DONALD
TRUMP HASN'T BEEN TALKING
TALKING TO THE NORTH KOREANS FOR
A LONG TIME HERE'S AN INTERVIEW
BACK IN 1999.
>> WE HAVE A COUNTRY OUT THERE,
NORTH KOREA, WHICH IS SORT OF
WHACKO AND NOT A BUNCH OF
DUMMIES AND THEY ARE GOING OUT
AND DEVELOPING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THEY ARE NOT DOING IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE HAVING FUN DOING IT.
THEY ARE DOING IT FOR A REASON.
WOULDN'T IT BE GOOD TO SIT DOWN
AND REALLY NEGOTIATE SOMETHING?
THAT NEGOTIATION DOESN'T WORK,
SOLVE THE PROBLEM NOW RATHER
THAN LATER.
>> Bret: OUR PANEL.
CHARLES FROM THE WASHINGTON
"TIMES," AMY HOST OF NO LABELS
RADIO AND TOM A WRITER FOR THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER.
TOM, YOU WROTE THIS IS PROGRESS.
>> IT IS PROGRESS.
IT IS PROGRESS IN THE SENSE THAT
FINALLY NORTH KOREA HAS PUT
ITSELF IN A POSITION TO AT LEAST
TALK ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
SUSPENSION OF THESE PROBLEMS.
BALLISTIC MISSILES ARE CRITIC.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYTHING
TO LOSE IF THE PRESIDENT MEETS
WITH KIM JONG-UN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND 72 AFTER THEY GET
THE INSPECTORS IN.
WE COULD HAVE 2 WEEKS OF SNAP
INSPECTIONS.
THE WORST CASE IS YOU HAVE SPENT
3 OR 4 WEEKS DOING SOMETHING
UNUSUAL, BUT YOU HAVE NOT WASTED
MONTHS.
WASTING MONTHS WOULD MEAN THEIR
DEVELOPMENT TO THE BALLISTIC
MISSILES.
IF THIS WORKS GREAT.
.WE HAVE NOT LOST THAT MUCH
TIME.
>> Bret: IS IT A FACT THESE
SANCTION VISIT HAD AN EFFECT?
THEY HAVE SQUEEZED HIM ENOUGH HE
WAS FEELING IT?
DO WE BELIEVE THAT TO BE A FACT?
>> WE DO.
I HAVE GIVEN THIS ADMINISTRATION
GREAT CREDIT FOR GOING FURTHER
THAN PAST ONES.
SQUEEZING THE CHINESE.
GETTING SANCTIONS OUT OF THE
U.N., BUT I THINK TOM'S WRITINGS
ON THIS.
THEY NEED A LITTLE MORE TIME TO
REACH OPERATIONAL CAPACITY.
TALKING ABOUT HALTING TESTS
WHILE THEY COMPLETE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR ARSENAL,
THIS PROVIDES THEM MORE TIME.
THESE ARE PROMISES THEY HAVE
NEVER KEPT.
WHY WOULD YOU BE GETTING SO
CLOSE TO COMPLETING YOUR MISSION
THAT YOU HAVE PUT A PRIORITY
ABOVE ALL ELSE AND STARVED YOUR
PEOPLE FOR, WHY FOLD NOW?
THIS IS NOT NATION THAT KEEPS
ITS PROMISES.
THE PRESIDENT'S SPOKESWOMAN SAID
SOMEONE GOT TO HIM AND SAID YOU
NEED TO MAKE CLEAR YOU NEED
INSPECTIONS BEFORE YOU SIT DOWN.
>> Bret: YES, HENCE THE 8
CONCRETES FROM SARAH SANDERS.
SUPPORTERS SAY THIS WAS PART OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE TALKED
IN A BELLICOSE WAY OF "FIRE AND
FURY" AND ALL OF THE TWEETS AND
HOW BIG IS YOUR BUTTON AND ALL
OF THAT?
THIS LED TO A CHANGE IN THE
DYNAMIC.
CRITICS SAY SITTING DOWN WITH
KIM JONG-UN, YOU ARE GIVING HIM
EXACTLY WHAT HE WANTS.
LEGITIMACY UP AGAINST AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
>> SURE, BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO
MINIMIZE THE PART ABOUT SOME OF
THE BELLICOSE REMARKS.
LAST WEEK WE THE PRESIDENT
JOKING WITH THE DANGERS OF
MEETING WITH A MADMAN AND HE
SAID THAT'S HIS PROBLEM.
>> THAT WAS THE DINNER.
>> YES.
I THINK STUFF COULD BE PLAYING
CRAZY IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO
IT.
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF WARNED
AGAINST FALSE HOPES.
THIS COULD BE FOOT DRAGGING.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE THIS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THAN
SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S -- WE KNOW
THAT 20 YEARS OF PATIENCE WHICH
IS DIPLOMAT SPEAK FOR WE GOT
NOTHING OR I AM NOT DOING
ANYTHING HASN'T WORKED OUT VERY
WELL FOR US.
MAYBE TRYING TO GET MOVEMENT IS
NOT A BAD THING.
>> Bret: FOR REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
REACTING TO THIS AND CAUTIOUSLY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN HE
CAMPAIGNED SAID HE WOULD MEET
WITH KIM JONG-UN AND OTHER
LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD.
>> HE WAS CRITICIZED FOR THAT.
THE KEY ISSUE HERE, THOUGH, IS
WHY DOESN'T THE PRESIDENT MEET
WITH KIM JONG-UN BEFORE MAY?
THE KEY IS TO TEST AS QUICKLY AS
YOU CAN.
HAVE THAT MEETING AND GET THE
INSPECTORS IN.
>> Bret: THE DIPLOMATS SAY ARE
THEY READY?
>> WHAT IS THERE TO BE READY
ABOUT?
>> Bret: ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE INSPECTORS AFTER THEY
LEAVE THE TABLE?
>> I THINK IS STUFF YOU CAN GET
DONE QUICKLY IF YOU NEED TO.
THAT SHOULD BE THE FACTOR.
>> DOES IT HAPPEN QUICKLY?